i'm not a chef i have no culinary skill
i learned how to bring people together
through food and i've been doing that
for a very long time
i was always a business owner
not the one on paper but i was always a
business owner
i used to sell frozen cups where you
freeze the juice in the foam cup and
then you sell it people knock on the
door i used to sell that
outside of the parties i used to sell
mcchickens i would go to mcdonald's and
buy mcchickens for a dollar and come
back and sell them for two dollars i
would sell anything that i could because
i'm like i'm a hustler and they used to
call me hustleman because i literally
would find ways to create things that
people needed and when i realized that i
can create a need for people and they
could i could be their supplier i knew
that there was a big win for me and then
i got a mouthpiece out of this world so
i could get people to buy anything that
i'm selling and it always worked as a
kid
i was born and raised in baltimore
maryland my father the day that i was
born he was being sentenced
to 30 plus years in prison so i grew up
in a household with my mother and my
siblings
and she worked every day she was a
workaholic maybe that's where i get it
from but she worked at mcdonald's she
was on payroll she's the lead singer of
a reggae band and i saw that my mother
really never rested but she always made
sure that we had what we needed not
always what we wanted so i learned how
to be a hustler and not beg anybody for
anything and always get it on my own
because i saw how hard my mother worked
my father was also an entrepreneur just
wasn't the legal one
and he literally did what he could to
provide a way for his family as well so
i've always been in that entrepreneurial
world
growing up i used to sell candy food
everything you could think of because i
just had that itch
i was 14 having high school parties and
i can remember calling rec centers and
facilities acting like an adult so that
i could secure the venue to have parties
and i used to bring out a thousand
people
every single week
that would come to my parties and i
remember counting like four thousand
dollars on the floor with my mother
every other week and that was something
that i've never seen before because here
i am i'm a teenager i'm just getting out
of my preteens
and my mother helping me to count money
making more than my mother at a young
age and i realized that entrepreneurial
life is the life that i need to live and
the rest is in history as a jamaican
food was always big i laugh about eating
rice and peas every single day of the
week
but i always had a home-cooked meal and
although my mother wasn't home all of
the time because she was working
my grandmother was in the house so she
told me how to cook
she was a baker i didn't get that part
down but she was just the person that
just taught me how to make flavor taste
good
and i learned so much from her um and i
grew up in a household with a mother
who's a vegetarian so i grew up just
eating fish so after i graduated college
i got into tv and i was really good at
it and it afforded me the opportunity to
move to new york city where i became a
producer on a few shows saved up my 401k
and i opened up my first restaurant it
was called pinkie's jamaican and
american restaurant and the restaurant
did seemingly well had lines down the
block but unfortunately fortunately and
unfortunately i lost that restaurant to
a grease fire but i'm glad it happened
because what it did is it took me out of
that restaurant so that i could focus on
other things i was only supposed to come
to atlanta for three months and when i
came to atlanta that's when i came up
with [ __ ] vegan and that [ __ ] vegan
concept literally started in my bedroom
my two bedroom apartment in atlanta and
after i came up with that concept i had
no idea that it would turn into a 100
million dollar brand
i hired like three chefs to come to my
house to make food the original concept
was supposed to be called the jackfruit
cafe i was gonna make everything with
jackfruit
and then the chef came to my house and
it was disgusting and i'm like okay well
i can't do this so what am i gonna do so
i was working with uh the shared kitchen
and they recommended me a company called
impossible and they said that there's
this new company called impossible foods
they make um
vegan burgers they taste really good do
you want to sample it i'm like sure so i
tasted the burger and i'm like oh my
gosh this is so good i'm gonna make
burgers and fries i made the sauce from
scratch i was just playing throwing
stuff in a bowl mixing it and i made
like a thousand island kind of dressing
from scratch and then i made a fry
seasoning from scratch just throwing
stuff together in a bowl and i came up
with the recipes and i put them on this
burger i'm not even a chef i just like
to eat
and it worked and not only did it work
in a major way like people from around
the world go crazy about our secret
sauce
people from around the world go crazy
about our fry seasoning you don't have
to be an expert you don't have to be
somebody who's doing it for years as
long as you got a creative hand and a
creative mind you literally can make
something so spectacular that people
crave every single day but i realized
that we created a phenomenon
we created something that people had an
appetite for and i'm not talking about
the food people wanted to be a part of
this movement
and that movement allowed me the
opportunity to open up my first brick
and mortar that dream afforded me the
opportunity to open up additional
locations and to eventually raise 25
million dollars to be able to scale and
grow my business so all of these things
we've been doing in a grassroots way to
grow this company and now here we are on
our way to be a billion dollar brand
i used to just be that person like oh i
want to do this idea but i don't have
the resources i don't have the
information now it ain't nothing that i
can't do so when you ask me when do i
know i'm going to make it i don't know
i'm just doing the work and just having
fun while i'm doing it
you